what's the difference between probation
and parole probation is what you usually
get instead of being locked up it means
that judge agrees that instead of
sending you to prison or jail you can go
back into the community but with
conditions on your freedom these
conditions can include curfews rehab
programs paying a fine or having to
check in with a probation officer every
month or sometimes more often
traditionally it all comes after you've
already served some clothes
it's an early release but there are
still conditions on your freedom until
the end of your original sentence
violating the conditions of your
probation or parole like drinking
alcohol or missing appointments with
your social worker can land you back on
the cellblock even if you haven't
committed a new crime
you